hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one important and helpful clarifying
discussion that takes place in the
article corporate governance and ethics
of feminist perspective is about how the
ethics of care
would impinge upon and perhaps
complement more traditional masculine
Associated theories that focus on
Justice and also focus on rights and the
idea is that an ethics of care isn't
going to Simply dismiss rights or
dismiss discussions of justice but is
going to allow a better understanding of
these that will also be more effective
in you know protecting and recognizing
people's rights now as the authors point
out the ethics of care in its Origins uh
you know we're talking about 60s 70s 80s
it was originally rather suspicious
of what was viewed as as masculine
derived discourses about Justice and
rights and and you know there was a
contrast between an ethics of care and
an ethics of Justice
um there was suspicion about rights
understood in a very individualistic way
so there's you know some some uh
contrast being raised at the time but
then quite quickly feminists were also
saying well we don't want to get rid of
Rights altogether because women in fact
need their rights to be recognized and
respected particularly in the workplace
so they need their rights acknowledged
and and protected
um
and uh here we go the the history of
feminism as the authors are pointing out
is tantamount to the struggle for
women's rights and emancipation
emancipation would mean being treated as
an equal right so one person Brennan
argues feminists have claimed it's the
individualism and abstraction linked
with talks of Rights and responsibility
which is problematic not the concept of
Rights and responsibility themselves so
then if that's the case
how would rights be reevaluated and
reconceptualized well there's a really
great article by Annette buyer the need
for more than Justice that was really
Central in the ethics of care and
feminist ethics that gets brought up
here
and is it the summary goes buyer argues
that traditional rights theories has a
number of weaknesses especially relating
to its conceptual conceptualization of
Rights governing relationships between
equals so what does that mean well the
traditional conception of Rights is that
I simply have my rights and you have
your rights and they're inherent in us
and they exist in US sort of as
individuals whether you and I are
connected in any sort of way and our
rights are equal so that you're you know
on the same level as I am
excuse me and that's very often not the
case in real life relationships we do
have rights but the rights take place
across power differentials what are
Power differentials it's when we're not
on the same level and when our rights
might not be respected or recognized in
the same way so buyer points out
examples of relationships where power is
unequally distributed great example of
this parents and children another
doctors and patients
in other states and citizens and within
a business context what might we imagine
well think about reporting structures
right uh if you report to somebody there
is a power differential right there
because they can write you up right and
and they're the ones who tell you what
to do and they're the ones who apply the
criteria for whether you're doing your
job right or not there could be all
sorts of power differentials as well
this is painfully aware to you whenever
you need to call customer service for a
product that's not working there's a
power differential between say a company
and a consumer or there may be power
differentials as well you know think
about small business between one small
business supplier and another small
business who who's using their products
there's all sorts of ways in which power
can be unevenly distributed some of it
can even be contextual for example you
make some sort of uh screw-up or you're
perceived to do so you get called into
HR suddenly you're in somebody's office
you're sweating you're not quite sure
whether you're in trouble or not right
there's a power differential there isn't
there when somebody's training somebody
else there's a power differential so all
of these are important situations
now uh according to buyer and ethics of
care it would be needed why so that
rights then are placed into relational
contexts they're not understood as
simply these abstractions that we we
have so rights are not gotten rid of but
they're reconceptualized another
theorist Reddick talks about and she's
focusing primarily on uh in her article
on situations in which you know agencies
have to intervene for example in crime
abuse things like that
she talks about uh um the full complex
of needs that families serve she says
more or less intervene in the name of
Justice to impose fairness or forbid
assault forbidding assault is protecting
rights uh you know producing Justice
that's another way of enforcing rights
but they're going to be more effective
if they do so within a certain context
that is furthered by the ethics of care
so she advocates for example engaging
the moral agency of those they seek to
change or protect if they govern their
their intervention by the ideals of
humility and mutuality associated with
care so how might this actually play
itself out
there can there needs to be some sort of
uh connection so I'm sort of involvement
you see this very often you know in in
other professional contexts like good
policing or a good Social Work
intervention
um you treat the other person not just
as a bearer of Rights or as an
individual within a system in which
things have to be allocated fairly but
is somebody in relationships you say to
them for example okay I understand that
you're imposing force on this person is
that really what you want just to be a
tyrant who is you know imposing their
will uh you want to have your your
Viewpoint respected don't you you're
you're really you know undercutting
yourself by imposing force on this
person and essentially terrorizing them
you're not going to get what it is that
you want from them and and you know you
might say well you're you know you're
not treating the victim right then and
you're coddling the aggressor well you
can also do the same thing with the
victim you can say don't you want
something more than this you probably
are going going to need to to you know
be more assertive on your part and we'll
give you support to do that now think
about how this might play out for
example in instances of workplace
harassment and bullying the ethics of
care uh you know would say we need more
than just simply imposing the rules or
carrying out some sort of abstract
reasoning we need to reach these people
as people
so the upshot of this as they summarize
is that feminist ethicists want to flesh
out the context of Rights they want to
make rights more robust and substantial
by introducing tenets of a care
perspective what are those tenants
relationships with concrete others not
just treating people as abstractions or
as tokens but but really you know
focusing on relationships the practice
of responsibility on the part of the
agent and on the part of everybody else
involved including responsibility to
self so that you don't burn out and the
notion of empowerment through care in
unequal relationships the idea of the
ethics of care is not to Simply
introduce a kind of new dependency where
now you are you know helping everybody
all the time or supporting people all
the time or on call for those people all
the time you ultimately want to help
Foster them so that they can you know
stand up for their own rights and
enforce that and then go on and do that
for other people as well now all of this
has a lot of implications for what
business ethics would say about what
goes on within companies uh you know
whether they're large corporations or
small companies and relations between
companies and their stakeholders